poi vedere con cosa ti e presenti nei
miei video fai vedere fai vedere da rete
perché hai una banana e brigo fame e fa
bene a mandare a pranzo parco 2 faccio
la doccia faccio la doccia mentre cinque
minuti 56 anni però cedere sui capelli
sono tutto pulito grazie non ti fa un po
schifo mentre lui si mangia la banana io
gli spiego che cosa consiste il video di
oggi tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono qua vj lui e lorenzo
il mangia banane nel capito che devo
dire siamo ragazzi su di haydn lower con
la scossa elettrica di egger lover è un
gioco dove praticamente lui ti mette in
paragone del tipo questo caso ti avrei
amori oggi la viola la lav si univa live
e poi dall'altra parte c'è salute
mentale c'è una roba a caso e tu devi
indovinare quale delle due alle app più
click su google europei secondo me in
questo canale di andare ducati per la
bocca piena
no soprattutto se una banana in questo
caso questo caso secondo me è più basso
salute mentale secondo me va bene e
sbagliato mai giusto 165.000
assolutamente ok in questo caso è tra
salute mentale beethoven secondo me
beethoven è più alto
decisamente vedi questo è il gioco
capito adesso che abbiamo capito come il
gioco ti spiego che cosa consiste quando
arriviamo a 10 la scossa passa a me ho
neanche il social facebook fatto sta
roba
e giuro perché mica go addosso non
provare non me ne frega un cazzo di
sapere come non so se funziona va
malissimo
no non schiacciare un dura no no no che
lo schiacciamento della rossa no non
schiacciare ma si erano ramagli è fatto
stato ea uno frate ora questo il parente
lo non te lo fanno allora e lo
resteranno rischiare raga è una roba che
ha paura del 2017
allora ti faccio partire con una facile
che siamo già su beethoven e jennifer
aniston beethoven è più cliccato
d'igiene per anni
indi per cui davvero secondo te
beethoven e più cliccati jennifer
aniston non mi rompere i [__] si
riferiscano almeno click di ben 20
dell'it e ti guarda ora che cosa dovevo
solo sarei tornato
tg clan dovevo solo stare zitto no è più
cliccata leggono nell artico
sinceramente poi non lo so molto bene
molto bene
meno 8 mafia 3 o il granchi
in generale i granchi ranchi non è
andata ha dato 6 perda ma perché fa così
male ti giuro che sincero va male eh sì
perché mi dà proprio fastidio si sente
che fa male che governerà o salvate il
soldato ryan l'ha visto film si passa e
più cliccato questo quindi ai lager dai
loro era valori infine può essere
divenire molto di più
cosa questa riunione ecco ignorante
andata bene che la conosce john mack
vabbè mi chiedo se i tecnici sono queste
l'unione è certo è proprio una roba dove
tanti mali stati dentro frate
bravissimo figlia raga perché
calcolatrice perché lesbians l'altissimo
lesbiche o calcolatrice però lesbiche
senato parte certo lesbiche o l'adozione
vai vai vai io sono bravo perché ti
faccio aspettare la legge insomma meno
te l'aspetti
io ho veramente un male poi e ma poi io
posso andare così tutto il giorno sono
arrivati a 10 fra tematici la5 sports
direct o amazon informi della foresta
della male no a dio dai e perché persone
dati presso la foresta dell'amazzonia se
perde altre due volte e basta è finita
vabbè wikilekas tortura da madonna dalle
orecchie sorveglianza o bruno ma nata
come si guarda lo so povero cane cosa
stanno facendo questi buona gli servi ne
sta trattando malissimo euro promos
molto di più se a 20 quindi stai andando
bene benissimo perdita di peso bruno
mars perdita di peso
no perdi peso di più
sì ma grande fan culo ma [__] e
tamino sarebbe sa quante a matera anche
adesso che non è più ketamina si sa che
secondo me è uguale che cui crimi che ti
sei salvato una maglia di prima fila di
più contraccezione zio sbagli va bene
tipico la processione è invogliato ahi
ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi a te l'ho detto che
vogliamo è l'ultimissimo qualunque sia
il mio scopo è behrami ora che hanno
rifatta la casa disagio si scrive no
sotto ve lo dico io non rifatte sta roba
a casa c'è venite a trovare lorenzo
piuttosto gillette o 20th century fox he
di più twenty century fox ha sbagliato
mi spiego a parare plan di casa finché
sembravo rocchi
il rookie blake ammazza di botte
veramente una genova
sei un bastardo sei un bastardo e ci
sarà uno youtuber in meno sono telefono
stato bellissimo ma questo guarda gratis
l'ultimo che mai fatto ma che bel
braccio qua del guardan
questo gioco vera che merda sei stato
molto bravo avevano avrei a te l'onore
della poltrona del terrore io vi giuro
su dio che non so perché ho deciso di
portare sul mio canale questa roba
l'elettricità che mi fa di un male dove
lo mettiamo
nel culo caro amico ti sfido io sto
rilassato proprio difficile vicino
materico dovuto contentare adesso sono
qua dove c'è no no no fra i design che
nordi o dai carri ma di lorenzi non ce
la faccio li apri braccio chiama ci
batteremo ammazza tu non puoi mettere no
ti prego
giuro che non parla lo stronzo claudio
non ti ho fatto niente se non con lei ti
fai ma [__] a mike tyson all
ultima cena mike tyson
vai così l'arte nel culo l'ultima cena o
democrazia
anche ora che 67 mo krazia o angelina
jolie e angelina jolie dio santo quanto
cercato questa donna geri o budweiser
minchia rega
tirate posso mettere la mano matte non
pensare a questo pensando cultura
angelina michelis un alcolizzato non so
chi sia neanche io però se qui non dormi
giochi
lo vedo titubante si leonardo leonardo
ajax vai a davide golia blood diamond
blood diamond zio non so david e golia o
lo stadio anfield e l'eco della stadio
calcio di merda cioè calcio di merda non
date non ci riesco allora mi vendo il
mio telecomando chiudi gli occhi e che
non va a 3
hamas è poco un pezzo di merda sei un
pezzo di merda abbassa il chievo è certo
la regata che cazzo ridi gli unanimi
riguarda i sì sono un uomo sono sono un
uomo fi che ogni tua mamma io sono solo
un uomo e non so se sono un uomo
[Musica]
è bruttissimo mettono davanti allo zio
fa malissimo è uguale
sei arrivato a diventato vinti dai dai
che ne so io geocaching car wash
geocaching buon andata bene che non la
macchina carroccio santorini madonna
frate madonna santorini o mosè lui
divide le acque a santorini perché mosè
de separava le acque ma gerusalemme
normale un sanicola va nessuno che
brutto gioco che è brutto gioco di avere
minchia 5 milioni pena di morte che la
stessa cosa se sbagli questo etero e
poggia sul collo e michela pena di morte
odore del corpo pena di morte puzzilli
schifo madonna la gente non puzza mai a
8 bangkok 9 a crono nove film cacciatori
film hai visto
mica zio sono a 9 faccio uno vinto fai
queste vinta infatti del 10 ma sei
deficiente 6 deficiente se abbiano la
sbagli poi foglia fabbricarlo a cliccare
dai veleni non ultimo saluto di all
ultimo sbagliato a cliccare con un
momento assolutamente bangkok veramente
ti faccio quest'area ti do questa
possibilità ti faccio io tre domande
devi indovinarne due su tre in quante
squadre ha giocato roberto bacheca frode
di fiction o roberto baggio giocato
nell'inter tutte le tue domande di merda
sul calcio porta ed io ti sto parlando
di dio non seguo io sì sì un'altra
domanda è facile quante gambe ax non ha
le gambe le tante mi piace
sei tutto scivolato 6 tutto se quando il
mio compleanno il 4 aprile è giusto
guardare e non toccare qui è giusto
zitti e scoprirai serie è giusto lo so
che è giusto se c'è motivo è bruttissima
l'attesa smettila è lentissimo fallo è
il 24 si sceglie inoltre fede andando ad
oggi me lo togli melo basta odioso e dai
ragazzi grazie aver visto questo video
io sono contentissimo di fare lo
youtuber come mestiere
una cosa che volevo fare sin da piccolo
darmi la scossa per guadagnare
fantastico grazie ai frati che mi
accompagni queste sfide incredibili velo
dato l'onore che i ragazzi elettrizzante
queste 2017 se non avete riso lasciate
mi piace cosa molto provato
quindi ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto
cose e mi piace anche ai vari social
comunista torna descrizione ci sono liti
fiscali ci vediamo al prossimo video
prendi lavoro per ragazzi dai
coordinazioni caxxo secondo me lo
prendeva il tu no però dai ragazzi